Michelle yo yo has become the first
person identifying as Asian to win the
Oscar for best actress I did not stumble
I did not misread that this is a
breaking according to NPR Michelle yo
wins Oscar for best actress making
history as the first person who
identifies as Asian to win the award we
all are simply people who identify none
of us really is anything at all now the
reason they use this language apparently
is that some other actress had already
won the first Asian actress had already
won but she didn't wear her ethnicity on
her chest on a big sticker that she put
on her forehead that said I am Asian so
therefore we now have to celebrate it
again because an actress who I
identifies as Asian wanted okay